hey everyone this is kevin from
thechesswebsite.com and today we are in
game number 10 of our coverage of the
2021 world chess championships being
held in dubai between madness crossing
the champion and yan nepo the challenger
reminder this is a best of 14 series
meaning the first player to seven and a
half points will be victorious you get
one full point for a win half a point
for a draw coming into game number ten
madness carlson has six points janepo
has three points meaning madness carlson
is getting closer and closer to
retaining
his title three the last four games have
been win so it started out it looked
like he was just going to be draw after
draw but you could see some glimpses
both players were trying some creative
things in the first few games we just
had a lot of draws there were no
mistakes there's been more mistakes that
the past few games and it's led to a lot
of victories for managed carlson because
he has not been making those mistakes we
did see a big blunder yesterday from
janepa where he got his bishop trapped
and that went on for a pretty easy
in-game victory for madish carlson so
today madness crosston playing the white
pieces
game number 10 has an opportunity to get
even closer to the championship and he
starts out with e4
e5 knight f3 nepo decides hey let's go
ahead and go back to the petrov defense
which magnus crossing very very familiar
with decides to take here on e5 and
after pawn to d6 we see an interesting
move from manish carlson you know
typically and even in a previous game
we've seen the world championship the
knight comes back to f3 this is the most
common line knight takes here pawn up to
d4 maybe pawn d5 as we've seen bishop to
d3
and then starting to attack this knight
with other moves you could see
knight to c3 knight to d2 you have some
other options here if you want to but
madness carlson plays
the not so common move of knight to
d3 now he did actually play this exact
variation in 2018 the last world
championship against fabiano caruana
that was game number six if you wanted
to go back and and check that out i have
coverage of that game as well but if you
remember the 2018 world chess
championships it was very drawish both
sides just could not get anything done
uh fabiano actually played extremely
well in this game
but
at the end of the day this is a very
safe way for manus carlson to play the
petrol defense he's extremely
comfortable in this opening and knight
to d3 makes it very difficult for black
to find any opening
and attack him and that's i think what
madness carlson is trying to do he
recognizes that he is close to retaining
the title he's up three full points on
his opponent he wants to go for the
safest lines possible so after the
knight takes here on e4
then you play queen to e2 pinning down
this knight queen to e7 blocking that
and then you play knight to f4 now the
main line from here is knight to c6
followed by knight to d5 attacking the
queen here
uh you'll now usually see knight to d4
and these are the main lines that you
would typically see one cool variation
that could happen in this doesn't happen
all that often but
uh for those watching the the live
stream that they go through lots of
different variations uh in these kind of
obscure openings that you don't
typically see and usually haven't
analyzed a ton of and from here queen to
c4
since the queen's under attack and then
there is a nice little mate here after
knight to c3 this is a discovered attack
with the queen if the knight takes on e7
then you have knight takes c2 and this
is checkmate the knights doing all of
the work here uh both attacking the king
and then this other knight attacking the
additional squares so madness carlson
would have to fall for a pretty big
blunder there beyond nepo recognizing
that the most common played move for
black is knight to c6
and he can't really do the normal moves
here he has to try and be different he
plays the move knight to f6
now magnus crossing continues with d4
just controlling the center of the board
also opens up for the dark square bishop
to get involved knight to c6 pawn c3
solidifying the pawn chain pawn d5
knight over here to d2
knight comes back to d6 and i i don't
know if i really like this plan from yon
uh one idea that he has remember he has
to be pretty aggressive even though he
has the black pieces he's got to find a
way
to get a victory he essentially needs
three wins over
this game in the next four games so i
really like
bishop to
f5
and then try to castle on the queen side
it's risky but then you can just throw
everything at your opponent after they
play c3 you know white's typically not
going to castle on the queen side they
have blocked their bishop on f2 or on f1
so even when they castle on the king
side it will take some time that allows
you to
develop your pieces to really start to
attack you can start pushing forward
with your pawns here uh eyeing
everything down the king side for a big
strong attack and just hopefully madness
crossing can make a mistake i think you
let him off the hook when you play
something like knight to d8 uh because
it's just delaying and letting madness
carlson set up the proper defense and so
after knight two f3 the queen takes the
bishop takes here and you can see with
both of these queens it's really just uh
a waiting game to see who's going to
take because as soon as you take
a new exchange well magnus crosston
actually gains a tempo here because yes
he takes back the queen
but his bishop has now moved and you see
how it's a little bit different if
madness carlson takes this queen and
then all of a sudden y'all nepo can
actually take back and he has already
moved his bishop so i i feel like in
that exchange not only did dionepo give
up his most powerful piece that he
definitely needs in this game for a
strong attack uh but he's also just
giving madison crosston these little
incremental advantages that you just
don't want to give to madness carlson
bishop 2d6 kind of opening up to castle
on the king side so we see castle and
then castle on the kings side not my
favorite but it is what it is bishop 2
d3
rook 2 e8 attacking this open e5 i
always want to put your rooks on the
open files rook to e1 manuscripts and
says hey if you want to exchange off
material that is fine by me and that's
exactly what we see here on e1 knight to
e6 yeah don't want to keep it back here
on the eighth ring so brings it to e6
magnus crossing again hey let's exchange
material this is going to be fine for me
so the bishop takes both sides have a
bishop pair pawn to g3
and after pawn g6 we see knight two g2
so getting it off the first rank here
getting it more involved into the game
rook to e8 getting it to the open file
here pawn to f3 madness carlson
recognizing yeah we just block off all
of these squares the knight can't really
come to anything
at any point so blocking all of that off
also just stopping a lot of the squares
that the bishop can go to and since the
queen's off the board you don't have to
worry as much about pushing these pawns
and worrying about someone attacking
your king
at this point you kind of want to get
your king involved into the game knight
two h5 and then king f2
pawn c6 just solidifying the pawn chain
on the queen side of the board and then
pawn g4 no real good square for this
knight to go to can't come to f4 because
then you're just going to see an
exchange the knight and the bishop both
attacking the square here on f4 can't
just come down to g3 either so the
knight comes back to g7 again not able
to find any sort of attacking lines can
black bishop two f4 says let's exchange
material exactly managed carlson's
playing here knight takes on f4 pawn g5
attacking the knight knight comes back
to e2
pawn f5 trying to blow up the king side
of the board maybe they can get
something going on pawn to h3 just
solidifying the pawn
king 2 f7 activating it definitely need
to do that and then rook to h1 i like
the idea for madness cross and looks
like the only thing happening is on the
king side so he wants to get in that
support right now and maybe he can push
forward and find even a victory if
black allows can also just get your rook
behind enemy lines once your rook gets
on the seventh rank you can start to
attack these pawns here on a7 and b7 so
i think magnus crosston not only is
somewhat playing for a draw in some
respects but i also feel like he has the
best option if someone was going to win
this game
black continues with pawn h6 and then
pawn f4 blowing up the pawn structures
here
pawn takes backs bishop takes here and
then rook takes on h6 and this is also
setting up for the bishop to come here
to g6 attacking the king and the king
once it moves then the rook would fall
here on e8 yeah nepal realizes cannot
let that happen so bishop to f5 bishop
takes
here knight takes on f5 and then rook to
h7 kind of as we talked about after the
rook is on the seventh rank forcing the
king to move
you can see the threat over here uh
attacking these pawns so the knight has
to come back to g7 play some defense now
the pawn can take on g5 uh is now up a
panda material although yonepo can get
that material back but he's he's
fighting from a spot of coming from
behind there's no real way to get an
initiative getting into the in-game
madness carlson has not made a mistake
in the end game yet this tournament king
two g6 attacking the rook and the pawn
to get back that pawn and material rook
comes back h3 king takes here king 2
rook 2 g3 attacking the king and the
knight behind it king to f6 to hold on
to it
rook 2 f3 attacking the king all of a
sudden knight 2 f4 and kind of both
sides you want to get your knight on a
central outpost uh the central outpost
for manuscripts then is going to be this
e5 square and just really really
attacking all the critical squares uh
that black is going to be trying to move
to and from black standpoint wants to
get the knight here to e4 so that's
where both sides are going
king 2 d6 knight 2 g6 just maneuvering a
little bit rook 2 e6 yeah you're
attacking it doesn't matter because then
knight 2
e5 knight up to e8 trying to maneuver a
little bit because then it can come to
f6 and then e4 as we discussed rook two
f's
seven and then rook two f6 so this
pretty much just ends the game
this is forcing magnus carlsen to trade
off which he's completely fine at doing
uh it's check and attacking the rook you
just have to go ahead and take here so
after the knight takes uh then we see
king 2 e3 and this is a drawn game both
sides decide yeah there's no one going
to get a victory here uh you know magnus
carlsen could have tried the longest
game ever
but you know even still it's it's
symmetrical i don't see how anyone
improves from here
and so we'll probably see a three-fold
repetition pretty soon so they decide to
draw
and all of a sudden we have
four games left young nepo needs to win
three of them
just to tie
madness carlson and take it to tie
breakers if he wins the remaining four
then he would be
the champion spoiler alert though even
though it has not happened youneppo is
not going to win the next four that's
just my
expertise uh
of predicting the future that's just
what i think if you feel differently let
me know but i think madish carlson is
going to be the champion and i think
it's going to be sooner than later now
they do have a day off tomorrow to
prepare and then they'll come back for
three days
if by chance which it won't happen uh
there is a final day then they they're
gonna play three days after the rest day
take a day off and then come back for
game number 14. i don't think it'll take
that long remember madness carlson
already has six and a half points so all
he needs is one more point if he gets a
victory he wins if he gets two more
draws
he wins jan nepo has to win three of the
remaining four games so i thought manage
crosston played a really safe opening
today i did not expect anything
differently very hard for black to find
anything to possibly do to attack i
think he had an opportunity maybe to
castle on the queen side through
everything at the king's side he opted
for the safer line i just don't feel
like he has the confidence right now to
attack magnus cross and i think he
realizes that he could make a mistake
and then mattis crosston would
capitalize and this would be
over sooner than later madness crosstalk
could have easily gotten a victory if
black played incorrectly so that was
game number ten uh you know just a just
a lesson from madish carlson on how to
navigate the world championship but
thank you guys so much for watching this
series has been a
lot of fun watching the master
go to work but thanks again and i'll see
you
in two days after our rest day for game
number 11.
you